let's jump into this first story and
here's why there's two reasons why we
decided we're gonna we're gonna open up
the show leading with uh the Twitter
being dead Story the first and most
important thing is that it's um it's a
very slow news day nothing is nothing's
going on and this is the most important
thing to talk about no I'm just kidding
um it is a slow news day there is some
other stuff we can talk about but I
really thought it'd be super boring to
just be like another development in the
hunter Biden story in their you know the
feds rated uh Biden's pen was it the
Penn Biden Center whatever and that
happened in November and no one knew it
happened until now so it's like of
course there's weird corrupt stuff going
on but I'm just like let's talk about
something more interesting so I go on
Twitter and a bunch of people I follow
you can see this meme Alx says opening
up Twitter right now all the locked
profiles everyone started not everyone
but a lot of people started locking
their profiles high profile accounts
started locking their profiles so that
no one can retweet their content no one
can share their content yo you combine
that with the fact that all ready people
were reporting for the past couple of
weeks a weird algorithm change that
resulted in zero engagement and it feels
like Twitter is just totally dead this
feels like and I'm sure these people
will un private their account at some
point but it feels like how like
Canada's like offering assisted suicide
to people like if you want to kill
yourself we'll make it easy if you want
to block out your social media so we
don't have to ban you we'll make it you
know maybe they can incentivize you to
ban yourself so exactly self-selecting
and they're like removing themselves
from the gene pool so this is the crazy
thing right I I retweeted Chris
Martinson uh Doctor Chris Martin we've
been on the show
he he was talking about the MSNBC host I
brought up in the intro she she gets a
common cold but that results in
pericarditis and myocarditis I'm going
through my tweets because I I look at my
own tweets it's kind of like bookmarking
so when I retweet something I know like
here's the story I wanted I wanted to
post and it says this tweet is
unavailable because the account owner
protects his his tweets and I'm like oh
but I know Chris Martin said he's been
on the show before can't see his tweets
anymore he went private people are
basically Banning themselves anything I
shared from these accounts gone anybody
who follows me can't see him
it's it's like come on like these people
have it is strange to me that they were
convinced the only way to retain
engagement was to actually shut their
accounts down it's dead internet Theory
taken to like a whole new level but you
know honestly maybe maybe no no joke
what if what was really happening with
Twitter was that Twitter was falsely
boosting the numbers on tweets to make
it seem like there was engagement to
trick advertisers into spending money
and now that Elon Musk is cleaning up
the code he accidentally removed
whatever fake thing was there that
generated fake comments or fake likes
I'm not even playing it was the uh I
think the CEO of Reddit uh Alexis uh
what's his name Alexis Ohanian is that
his name
um I actually know Serena Williams right
yeah yeah yeah I know the guy he's a
very nice guy and I'm pretty sure him
and uh what's the other guy's name
Huffman talked about how in the early
days of Reddit they would pretend to be
users so that people would think there
was they were talking to people because
if you go on a social media platform and
comment known response you're like I'm
bored I leave so they would pretend to
be different people and comment and
create fake conversations and now
they'll ban you for doing that on Reddit
that's right oh yeah no I mean unless
you're you know the government I used to
do with mines I'd go on there and I'd
make a post a minds thing and then I'd
go on with my personal account be like
this is really cool upvote upvote
everyone when I was working as an admin
all the big tech companies they found
out they'd Banned Me instantly what if
that's it and the reason why when you
lock your account you get engagement is
because there's the locked engagement
fluffer and there's the uh unprivate
engagement fluffer I call them fluffers
you know what I mean like yeah you know
just make them big and uh and they only
got rid of the code on one of them dude
it does it makes me laugh because it's
like so many people who you know have
lauded other people for basically like
following Trends and you know just like
chasing the like chasing the clout and
now all of a sudden you know you're
seeing people like what's going on man I
only got 100 likes all and like they
wake up and the next day with like cold
sweats because they literally are not
getting the same engagements like is it
blows my mind just like whatever
hardwired people are to Twitter yeah
like and Instagram all of it man I feel
like Elon Musk is just like he's running
experiments and collecting data for the
aliens he's like hmm I wonder if they
deprived them of uh how are they going
to react and everyone everyone's
dopamine just dropped by like 80 and
they're like
like what are we doing Bros what like
what are we doing I thought we had real
lives we thought we touched the most
grass out of everybody on Twitter like
it reminds me of like I'm panning for
gold like uh there because I think
people are trying to find a way to crack
the algorithm back in the day on YouTube
if you could figure out how to post on
everyone's page at once then all of a
sudden your channel broke through the
algorithm and people could get really
famous in a relatively short amount of
time on social networks but a lot of
these networks now are like you know
they're ready for that so they're trying
to stop it from happening but people are
still like hoping they find some gold in
the river sift dude it used to be on
YouTube that you'd make a video where
you're talking about George W bush and
you know the war in Iraq but the
thumbnail was just like a big a big
tittied woman about I'm not even kidding
because people would click on it and so
you're like I don't know I'm not I'm not
a woman but if I'm gonna get those
clicks and the thumbnail would be like a
guy going like this and it would be like
war in Iraq and it'll be just like a big
large breasted woman next to him and
then it would get a million hits and
they used to do this thing too where
they would uh they would make videos
with fake thumbnails and fake titles and
when you clicked it it would just play
like it would show like a sentence and
it would play music and they would get
massively thumbs down but they generated
tons of hits YouTube started to clean
this up like okay we can't allow this
but if you look at some of the earliest
YouTubers and go look at their like big
ones and look at their YouTube channels
you will see they just for some reason
tended to have thumbnails that needed to
talk about women in bikinis Lisa Nova uh
huge in 2006 seven and I remember the
one the video that really popped off the
thumbnail was just a big butt crack and
all of a sudden it got millions of
clicks it was and I don't think it was
her butt crack it was like casim's
Castle G's butt crack shout out to
Castle well there was uh there's also
Casey neistat's famous video Make It
Count remember this one no it's the one
where he said that he was given a budget
to produce a commercial for for a Nike
and instead of doing that he just
traveled around the world in in 10 days
because it was more fun something like
that and then ended up being an amazing
commercial but the thumbnail for it is
two women in bikinis like posing and him
taking a picture so that like like
people knew exactly what they were doing
with how they engaged the crazy thing to
me is that we've we've created a points
system for our lives we've video
gamified yes politics and life like with
Twitter these are political
personalities being like I'm not getting
engagement anymore so I'm going to lock
my account to get more engagement and
I'm like that sounds like someone made a
mousetrap and put peanut butter in it
and you were like I'm gonna go in there
and get that peanut butter and then your
account gets locked all your retweets
are gone all your quote tweets are gone
it is it's like yo somebody at Twitter
figured out how to ban the conservatives
in One Sweep by getting them to walk
into the Trap themselves that's
hilarious bro but there are tons of
people who aren't on Twitter who like if
you explain this like everyone's locking
their account it's a big deal they're
gonna be like what I don't understand
because like Twitter feeds itself right
like when things start to irritate
people on Twitter it circles around like
there are parts of Twitter that won't
care about anything that's going on
engagement is sort of universal like
trying to drive traffic to your profile
is like the one unifying front through
all of Twitter and even then there are
tons of people who don't use the
platform who who don't care about this
hey let's just call it what he is bro
like
we discovered the meta the like the the
one meta build on Twitter and the mods
got mad and they patched it and now
everybody's all just like freaking out
so honestly I'm trying to figure this
out what if all the conservatives just
kind of like lock their accounts or
everybody's conservative and independent
just like their accounts and the
journalists literally can't like write
hit pieces anymore that's what I'm
thinking that we should all just like
it's actually a good point I was gonna I
was gonna say that all of these accounts
that locked their tweets lots of like
their all these all these people that
like their accounts all the news
articles that I've recorded those tweets
gone they're now going to show Dead
Space oh man oh if they unlock their
account they don't they don't repopulate
right I think it will go back you think
so yeah yeah because that'd be
interesting too if you just like
periodically like lock your account for
24 hours so like if anyone who's used
your stuff can't get access to it yeah
look I like Elon I like Elon Musk you
know I'm glad that he got Twitter I'm
glad he released Twitter files I think
he could do better but you know he's
doing what he can but I got to be honest
if Twitter I woke up tomorrow and it was
gone I'd I'd be happy I'd use mines it's
just a piece of tech the same as YouTube
like internet video is where it's at it
doesn't matter what network you're on
internet video is the powerful tool yeah
um I think that a lot of these problems
people are see searching for a way to
break an algorithm that they don't
understand because the code is private
if the code was public and you could see
what the algorithm is doing you would
know whether or not this was going to
have any value locking your hand you
wouldn't have to do it are you saying we
should free the code yeah yeah drink
free the code baby there we go guys
someone suggested me and you arm wrestle
I don't think it's gonna happen dude are
you ready I don't think I could take you
with two arms
I don't know maybe two legs two legs and
two arms actually I got to be honest I'm
pretty sure you could just like lift Ian
with one arm bicep girl yeah what's an
average one arm bicep curl dude average
is probably like 40. but then again I
mean my wife she curls like 30 pound
dumbbell so she's kind of skewing
extremely high on that so
yeah honestly for me uh I think about 70
or 80 like dude imagine this news is so
slow I'm actually going to come off them
guess and just talk about my biceps
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time